patricia te estaba consultando cómo
avanzar ahora la jornada de gabriel
boric tenemos entendido que viajará
luego a santiago la capital del país
donde también realizará un
pronunciamiento verdad
así es bonito acaba de salir ahora mismo
del palacio se ha montado en su auto de
ahí se dirige al cerro castillo donde
tendrá una comida con sus ministros de
ahí se traslada en helicóptero a la
estación central uno de los puntos
claves donde se inician las grandes
alamedas de santiago que atravesará en
un auto junto a su ministra de interior
y cía sitges y de ahí llegará al palacio
de la moneda en la tarde para ser
recibido con honores por toda la guardia
que se encuentra ahí y a las siete de la
tarde está pendiente el discurso que
dará desde la plaza de la constitución a
la ciudadanía al pueblo en el que
marcarán las líneas pero que va a ser su
próximo gobierno eso es lo que se espera
en esta jornada muy emotiva que se vio
en las calles de chile con mucha
expectativa ante lo que pueda llegar por
este significativo cambio de rumbo y
cambio de mirada en el gobierno del país
para patricia también juramentó el
gabinete de gabriel boric que además de
caracterizarse por tener una histórica
mayoría femenina incluye además algunas
figuras muy destacadas en lo que es la
política de la escena social de chile
verdad
así es el propio presidente de boliche
marco que estaba muy orgulloso de este
gabinete feminista son 14 las ministras
frente a 10 los ministros en la primera
vez en la historia de chile en la que
hay más mujeres que hombres en un
gabinete es también la primera vez que
una figura clave del gobierno como es el
ministro del interior la ministra será
en este caso una mujer se trata de ti
así que es una mujer muy querida que
encabezó y tuvo un liderazgo claro
durante la pandemia al mando del colegio
médico que es muy querida por la
ciudadanía y que ha tenido un rol cada
vez también en la campaña electoral la
segunda vuelta para que fuera elegido
gabriel vóley se abren nuevas tiempos
marcados por un poder mucho más femenino
ya lo veíamos este 8 dm en las calles
donde muchas de las que van a ser
ministras también salieron a
manifestarse para lograr avanzar en
cuestiones de género en el país